so hello everybody i'm anna and before i
get into what we are doing here at
number 26 a brief introvert myself so i
did my PhD last year and i was working
on my topic was more of information
extraction working on the domain of null
natural language processing and
knowledge base extension so this is the
area i was working on so i'm here today
i'll be talking about what we are
exactly doing at number 26 and how does
data science and python go hand-in-hand
together and what you can do like
awesome stuff here so let's get started
so this is not a new problem like we
have been banking like for ages now like
but like when it comes to like
traditional banking strategies or like
the way we bang it still very Orthodox I
would say like still backdated like we
are still like my father still goes to
the bank and he was he wants to update
his checkbook or something so it's still
not we are not there yet but it's the
most important activity every person
does even if you were in some box you
want to save it you want to see like
okay how much can i have a budget on
like every month every week things like
that so just a small statistics like
this is from from a disruption in dec so
like it's it's a very fun fact so it's
actually true like an worry what i mean
by millenia is like it's usually our
generation x what you call it just look
it up in millennia like on google it's
like people born after 1980s so it's not
talking of like old people or like like
teenagers like it's a basically us so
it's a really really a very alarming
number so why so that that's the
scenario like we really do not want to
do a lot of banking like we want to go
to the local bank or stand in the queue
wait for hours no it's not a possibility
so we launched like a year and half back
and this is what we have as of now so
just a disclaimer before i go into bit
more details over here like it's not
like a marketing thing like i want to
present like what number two indices
does but in the long run like after few
slides where I go into you would make it
makes sense that why this kind of things
are important so
so first important thing is like we have
to have a real time banking like we
shouldn't wait for 34 days to see like
our credit card transaction got through
or is it was it cancelled and like wait
for ages and then the landlord shoots
your mail like hey I didn't receive your
arrange things like that second is you
should have a very unique login
experience like the app should kind of
know you it's it's a bank for you it's
not like you are there for the bank so
the cool thing about here is depending
on the location where you log in from if
you're in France of your you're in Spain
this background image actually change it
it's actually a video so it's it's a
very nice and a simple thing but it
really gives you a more personal touch
to the whole experience even more
important is this spring transaction
into a view like you want to see not
just where you spent but you can see the
logos like what kind of transactions we
have we have gone through like some
something like it's a food or it's a
leisure or these kind of things even
more like the more orthodox of the more
traditional ways like you want to send
some money to your friend to your mom
it's as simple as this you put the
number select the number in the name of
your desired recipient and there you go
you just send it like in which which
currency or like even if it's abroad you
can just put some some another euro or
like different currencies and you go
ahead talking even more like this is
actually the best feature i find it in
our app so you go somewhere you lose
your card what you do you need some cash
what do you have we call it BOTS island
so you can generate this code you can
walk to your nearest center which is
shown here with the maps it can be in
german like Rev a little or DM or
something like that you say like ok here
is the code and you have the account in
your the money in your account I need 50
bucks I just need not a cap to my hotel
or like I need to go to the airport the
reirig i would give you some cash that's
the power of it like a sharp turns to
ATM for you immediately I don't think
like any bank is giving that to you I
was talking of transparency and like
better insights like how every
transaction should look like this is how
we we have have it like like detailed
fine
details like where you spend what you
spend how you spend it even even more
like sometimes you often need a credit
amount like you bought something and you
want some a buffer amount like okay I
need some extra bucks to you really have
a holiday plan well nobody takes a
credit like well take away the pinch of
salt idea but let's say you have some
marriage or some medical treatment for
instance like which you need to do those
kind of things so we also allow this
kind of overdraft facilities yeah going
ahead so these are the things which are
there but how can we actually make it
even better like this these are the
things which a user should like
everybody should always have it so in
this talk I would try to touch three men
use cases and i want to show you like
how come date pug and data science and
more soon like what i did was in python
totally how those two come hand-in-hand
to solve this kind of scenarios so a use
case one maybe let's say so we have kind
of financial status of different kinds
of users so this is one user this is
another user this looks pretty nice very
nice trends and this is like totally
like out of the blue slag you have note
it's wrong to say you have no trend but
it's like totally random it looks like a
noise so this is the this is the case
like it's a different user different we
have every one of us in this room has a
different behave like a financial
pattern like how we spend how he save
etc what's what's the target here we
want to do some customer like very
specific predictions about their future
about different future financial status
next case this is I really love it
because often I have been in such
scenarios like I drank so much one
Friday night in the next day morning I
just forgot like okay whom I should Oh
what and where did that money go I
withdrew 50 euros i don't see like it's
one euro left in my purse I don't know
where it went so this is all is the case
so you really don't want this to happen
so what we are looking for is complete
transparency like where is that money
exactly what is that many I withdraw its
nowhere like I should I should be
accountable for that
what I'm trying to do here is perfect
classification like more like near like
very nice accurate like classifiers
build classifiers on top of it so that
you know where your money went I'll I'll
tell this a bit more in details i have
little slides so just ajust a sneak peek
so you can send money yes i said i can
send to your friend or your mom some so
it's a person to person or it can be a
person to let's say your your your
housing agency or like let's say you're
paying some is man annual tickets so
it's like a body or institute where you
can do a transaction so it's always
between a sender and recipient so we
technically call them as like money
beams and we like bank transactions the
third most important like this is where
like I often talk with other people and
this is like hey that everything works
fine on my laptop or how do i deploy
this is like over the over the month
since we like started the company so
this is the way we are growing so just
imagine what's gonna like just do the
math here and like predict like in next
six months one year where we are going
to go and so much of volume like over 15
million transactions we already have so
like this huge chunks of data like how
should we process that like in in real
time way okay so coming back so i was i
started with these three use cases i
just talked a bit more in detail flag
here and I that shows like what what
data science we are doing here so the
first case like you want to send you
want to be accountable for whatever you
spend your total transparency so let's
take the case one where you try to send
some money to your friend totally drunk
which you can see here is induce a beer
yeah somewhere here so these are the the
text which you usually put it like when
you are sending some money with the app
allows you to put some text is kind of
of course optional but when you when you
put something so you is just a word
cloud of what are the text people have
put their like when they try to transfer
so the idea here is do some natural
language processing
what I did was like this is the standard
things like you just prune off the the
the stop words in English German
whatever language it is and then you try
to limit eyes that you take the tokens
and you try to see like okay what is the
the root form of the world and what I
used was actually ordinate which is like
a syntactic database for for the English
language and you can also have like
synonyms and two names like okay if it's
a dog it's animal as a thing of things
like that so it's hypo names and hyper
names of those so once you have some
kind of word like you say like okay like
food for two or like a pizza and salad
so this kind of particular these are the
actually instances of concepts so
basically these are like the concept is
basically food so here you have some
examples like people are actually
putting this kind of text and the good
thing about is like you can actually
prune off this from a you can just also
take debit and dr. and you just try to
map with the super concept like okay
what's the most likely concept is good
belong to and you can actually score it
with werden it on Python you have this
nice library where you can ask for us
similarity score you can say that okay
how likely is it like dog is similar to
hotels and restaurants for instance you
to give you a score similarly with how
dog is similar to animal it will also
give your scores you just rank it
accordingly and you just take the
maximum one going further this is like
the first case where you just talk with
you send some reference take so this is
like one of the great signals we used in
our app like because whenever you send
some money on some time stamp this is
actually the mine analyst analysis
showed like the reference text holds a
lot of key to it the second was as I
said like you are trying to send some
money to some agency or you as you said
like as mon or somebody's taking some
money so this is more of a like a
classification tasks like we have
different kinds of transactions
sometimes we are unfortunate enough and
we do not have this kind of a merchant
identifier associated with those with
that kind of a transaction
that's where the problem comes like how
can we also because our aim is complete
transparency we need to give people like
where the money went for instance let's
say we have a piano here so vapiano we
can we have some transactions where we
we know the merchants we know like what
type of merchant he is I thought like
okay well why can't we just build a
glossy fur out of it like okay if it's a
merchant like of a certainty i like
puppy and okay there has to be you
cannot have like two thousand euros of
billet appear know it's very less likely
or let's say for itunes or like itunes
purchase you cannot have certainly a
huge yes there can be but it's there is
a certain range of values within which
like itunes usually people are buying
songs or like doing some app purchase
usually 1.99 2.99 it's a certain range
so i build like okay you take the type
of the come in like the company you take
the amount and you try to build a multi
class classifier so what you have here
are like the like the types of the
categories which belongs to her so I was
lazy enough not to just reverse encode
this like one I think is like ATM
transactions to our for like bars and
restaurants three or like grocery kind
of things and this is basically the
confusion matrix so what does the system
suggest it would should have been and
what the classy for actually outputs the
darker the cell that means the more
accurate you are so that's what you see
like I tried out with couple of
different strategies and this is what
turned out to be the best and if
somebody has ever worked with amazon
services so this is this this diagram is
given are created by amazon web service
mission learning the service machine
learning service so they are using this
multi class classifier and it works
pretty good coming next like so we also
saw like different different okay this
is the one part of it like giving
complete transparency the second is like
about you like forget like what you do
or like your friends or something but
it's about your own money where it's
going how is it being trained or let's
say coming
do you think so behind the scenes what
I'm using is like he had like a loads of
neural network nice talks or the last
two days so here just to be on the same
page I want to be give a very very short
thing that's basically a set of set of
nodes and the ages are actually trying
to take a kind of input from here and it
performs a mathematical operation on it
and it tries to give an output what we
have here are these are the hidden
layers and you have the output layer so
depending on your task you can have
number of out number of output layer so
if it's like say a binary classifier
like zero or one you can just have two
nodes or if it's a multi-class one you
can have like a BCD whatever you want
and depending on like I think there was
a very nice talk yesterday itself like
you see like out of ABCD the B has log
eighty percent probability soils like a
this this is the classifier which gives
a it should be like B or something and
then input essentially it's the size of
the feature set ok so I tried actually
both like the keyword is like you try to
fit this in and you don't need really
need to have like multi-layered once try
with the very basic one just one layered
one and see how it works getting like a
bit like I put this light is nothing to
worry here because it's very simple is
basically where I when I said like it
takes the input and it gives an output
so it's basically you have a set of
inputs and you have particular weights
associated with it is just a function
which is a aggregation like weighted sum
of all these values so this is basically
this so with W 1 X 1 W 2 X 2 and you had
a kind of bias to it so what you have is
a is a the function and usually this
function can be anything is you just
like any standard literature on neural
network you can have a set of function
so we have a multiple of things like we
don't know the number of hidden layers
we don't know the number of what
function should work best so what I did
was came up with a like a kind of a grid
search kind of a thing so which we'd say
like given a set of functions on a given
a set of
um in hidden hidden layer sighs I would
like to find a cave which gives me the
least error so what I'm using on the
back back end is like Cara's so we have
mentioned Cal skype sometimes quite a
lot of times in this conference so
basically this is a rapper let Phil on
top of tiana or tensorflow you can use
either of it this is really nice in my
opinion because you they have a very
nice documentation i really appreciate
like one should use it and give it a
shot yeah it's very configurable even
you can write your own custom course
wherever you want to and you just make a
call nicely you don't need to use
whatever they're providing this is
pretty nice in my plane so as I said
like you have a lot of activation
functions it can be sigmoid rectified
linear units and then tan age or
whatever you want to then is the number
of hidden layers because I was not sure
like which would work the best is it
like one layer to layer or like hundreds
of layers you never know and then is
final called the epoch thing which is
like the number of times or like say the
one pass from the input to the output is
defined as I epoch usually the more you
do it it takes a lot of time but the
added advantage is it it really gives
you a better em like gives a better
model like it the accuracy is getting
better and better but it really takes a
lot of time so here is a like a snapshot
of like the code legate's basically with
on cara's like you just define it's like
like mag design which like you take upon
you to put a solid layer sauce another
we've go on adding it exactly like it so
he is the input thing so this defines
the shape like okay what should be the
input shape like if you go back if you
just recollect the few slides back so
because I will get three inputs and one
output so you just define it as simple
as that so you hear you won't see like
any actual numbers because this is
actually a snapshot of like a method so
here I am just passing all the hidden
layer possible values I I wanted to have
like I don't want to say like okay
search from 1 to 1,000 I have a specific
set just for time concern I don't want
to keep the thing running forever
this is how you construct the hidden
layer but and this is finally you had
the outer layer and when I was running I
had a little bit of problem because this
part was not there and it was
complaining of a callback method it
didn't find one so i had to write a
small callback which is like kind of
telling the training like when you train
it it helps like to log like what are
the errors you you see like you it every
pass what is the loss you incur these
kind of things and one more important is
the yes the dropout just like this like
twenty five percent drop oh that is kind
of telling the network like don't over
fit that's that's a simple thing okay
okay so what we do here like as we said
like when we are talking of this
customer prediction models like it's
about your money so we just take your
data points for your past from the past
like you let's say days weeks or even
months and what I do is like you when
you train a model you take you have n
data points you take the n minus 1 and
you try to find the nf1 so you have you
just hold out n the last one and you
just strain on in n minus 1 and you try
to minimize the model it framed them all
in such a way so that the error is
minimized on n once you have this model
just read it did and now predict the n
plus 1 it as simple as that how do I
know if the prediction is good is given
by this prediction interval this is not
confidence interval prediction interval
is basically it's it's a it's a
guarantee like okay it can be
ninety-five percent like within this
ninety-five percent I'm confident that
my next value would lie here eighty-five
percent is this much fifty percent is
this mess so basically it takes this
like the last value plus the standard
deviation of the of the whole data set
the smaller it is and if you can predict
within that it's even better so don't
thing like ninety-five percent is more
like it's actually bad like it it's like
a very broad broad spectrum outside and
i'll come to this shortly and this is
some of the the colors have gone totally
okay so i just took those two users who
had this weird like one was pretty nice
and I think this is a different it
doesn't matter so I'm trying to predict
like the next two values next to do two
data points so one we just like always
lying in the negative and one who had
like a not so bad kind of a balance this
gives you like a nice and she's like
they're totally different because both
users are totally different but the
algorithm is totally agnostic to it it
doesn't really care like who you are the
third most important part or like let's
say where we always suffer like it's
always an issue for us scalability so
this is like the colorful set of all the
technical ecosystem maybes is there or
maybe did I miss something so yeah so we
are using mostly amazon and i'll just
show you like how the whole thing like
you have your models build you have your
algorithms written in python how you can
just apply it and run it in parallel
super scalable and totally robust so
anything new here like yeah Jenkins I
i'm pretty sure somebody would
definitely know it was like continuous
integration so it you never really never
never bothered like okay I have to
manually copy paste from s3 and browse
upload the jar and stuff like that it's
totally seamless and it's totally cool
let's say so this is like one of the
like workflows or let's say one of the
architecture we had so we use lot of
kinases stream kinases string is
basically a let's say a pipe where you
have data data packets coming in like
like in shards or like and each child
has got a set of data records and you
have like lot of in custom like record
processor from Java or even Python
Python they have this kcl which is the
skinny sees client which is like the
powerlifting is actually done by a java
java file the other thing they don't yet
have like cool like a Python client for
it so you have a lot of transactions
coming in for users you write it to the
dynamo DB which is like a columnar
database from amazon and we have a
stream Allah is also another internal
Kinesis stream on on dynamo which is
like table internal streams
if you say like Oh gates enable so it's
kind of little so any application or a
consumer can listen to that stream so
you have multiple like I didn't talk
about this so this is another
functionality but the time doesn't
permit me to speak so much like all the
functionalities we have I talked about
this so it makes a makes a call to this
machine learning API and then he tries
to predict like okay what would be the
what would be left on that so so you has
you spender you have beer you send some
text to your friend you're totally drunk
the transaction comes to your database
this this thing triggers it categorizes
for you and you just marks it like okay
that transaction was food that
transaction was beer or something like
that another way like where this neural
network thing is coming we call it the
offline thingy which is not running so
frequent but it's which is which is
running not so frequent which we run it
like in a perfect interval so here we
use a simple q service which is also
from amazon so the difference here is
like we put all the users who made some
transactions in a day and we have our
leg elastic beanstalk which is totally
like we put it in a like a scaling group
and once you define our easy to instance
or it's basically a box you can choose
when you create an instance if it's a
federal like RPM or debian whatever
package kind of box you want and you say
like okay you should scale and it's very
pretty nice like if somebody worked with
it you can say like okay if the CPU is
thirty percent for the last 5 minutes
add five more instance and keep on doing
it you can also put a threshold on the
upper limit a book I want maximum 100
instance thousand instant of more you
pay the more you get simple so here is
the docker I'll just show you like how
our life docker image looks like so the
moment you deploy so there's this docker
image which pulls all the things you
need okay I need to be pin store blah
blah blah blah and then you say okay run
this thing and so this every image is
basically it has this this part of
course of this Python code I showed you
which is making a call to Karros on and
it is having theanine is back end so
this is actually the docker image we are
using so basically
some like the libraries which I think
pretty like all of us have often fails
like this is missing that is missing
blah blah blah and it is at the set of
dependencies or the libraries you need
to do and this this thing is pretty
important because initially I was not
having this but this kills the build
time like once you do the you build the
image there is no need to repeatedly
grab that like okay once it's downloaded
you don't need to grab again care of and
a compile it from scratch so if you just
put this thing it would make it really
really fast really fast it just takes a
cached copy of it and then you say okay
put this application here and and you
say like okay that's my working
direction you just have to expose a port
and you just say like okay what's the
file or the what's the Python code you
actually want to run so it's like Python
observer that's how you would run from
your own local machine like Python mmm
that pie and here you have all your
logic maybe it's it's a it's a restful
api or something and say okay / users /
run something like that and then that
python script would do what it needs to
be done like round grape all the
transactions from the near unlit things
like that so this is actually the kind
of the deployment life cycle which we
maintain so we get hub we have a web
hook so anything we push it there
immediately notifies the Jenkins Jenkins
ponce it's like okay we start building
it this stuff and just recollect we just
saw like this steps like these are the
things it does one by one and that's
exactly what you see in the Jenkins
console like it does using a cache so
people so this this this is and once
it's one is once it's done it tries to
deploy it on the Amazon instance so the
trick here is you need to have a
application or an environment name so
and that name said let's say named Tom
and Jenkins you say like okay once
you're done deploy it to Tom that's
that's as simple as that so II to try to
fetch it usually you get from them if
you do if you make some mistake you
would complain it-it's very nice they
could say on a console like application
tom was not found things like that so
till this part ok we are deployed on
amazon and we show it showed it in the
last few slides and how
it scales basically like so the moment
you have too many requests as I said you
can you can configure your skeleton
scaling issues like that if you have
more than thirty percent like too many
requests coming in 45 minutes just add
five more instance so when you say at
five more instance it just grabs the
this docker image and I said okay copy
one two three four that's it so you have
like five instances doing the same thing
for you immediately okay so we're like
summarizing like what we talked about so
far so basically it's not just about
what we are doing as data size but it's
also that I really think like this is
one of the biggest things but since the
deployment like how to run it in
production is always an issue it's like
this is the old one in a new flask like
the python class which was like and yes
like the users first is our always
approach though we don't want to make
some solutions or like which which which
are not like everything is centered
around the user so what he wants what he
needs what are his needs what are his
budgeting me like it's a banking app
around the user so we try to get it to
that like accurately and this is like
seamless integration like we don't need
to bother about like if tomorrow we need
to roll out something immediately so
it's there is no human involve anywhere
you write your scripts upload it here
and then you're done okay and that's
what we are I am here looking somewhere
else and yes we are hiring so please
send us your CVS just go to our site
number 26 dotty and just look for your
favorite job and just click apply thank
you so much for your patience
okay thanks Lauren up I think that was
really cool to see you set up and the
first question is already coming in I
thank you for interesting [ __ ] just a
quick question how do you handle
deployment and versioning of your actual
model objects as I said like this
modeling of this the neural network
models I really do not care like the
which version do I need because it's
about you if you made ten transactions
today my model which I built last night
is obsolete how do you manage deployment
then just that part of the question yes
so when I run it so that batch thing on
the offline thing runs every day every
night when is the transaction is the
lowest point so it's easier transactions
build some more a lot of it and you just
store it because the app or the feature
we have is like a monthly prediction
thing so let's say we run it say first
of month you say okay depending on your
last n transactions we predict like next
end of this month it would be X amount
yeah yeah I'm still well I don't know
maybe I'm facing the question in a wrong
way buddy when you train a model e then
save it on s3 and when you know I don't
serve it industry I don't so when you
deploy a new taka container a new
instance of the app where does it get
the model from an artist at work when
you when you deploy the new new
container so it's a okay so you have a
lot of requests coming in so you have a
user so you have likes a lot of hundreds
and thousands of users for each user
when when the docker container this
Python thing is running so the chaos
thing builds and it builds a model out
of it and it predicts what would be your
next value and it stores in the database
so the ah ok so you don't actually store
a model no no I just throw the pressure
all the data yeah is the model so if
it's a monday prediction or I really
don't care like okay tomorrow or day
after tomorrow if you make some purchase
I'm robust to that because it's so I
don't that would be stupid like if I see
your and go on updating so it would be
more and more accurate but if it's let's
say a weekly prediction so I have to run
it more frequently for you basically so
our our use case or the feature we have
is like a monthly prediction thing so we
just create content as okay this is your
prediction X you just store it
sendo quiz in the back thank you for the
doc yeah and did you also try tensorflow
no okay thank you yeah did you also talk
try cafe no because when I read up
initially was like Tiana was like more
of an academic choice and it seems
pretty good and I when I looked at the
document i liked it okay give it a shot
yeah like whatever it needs to get the
things done and with that reasonable
amount of accuracy here's another
question yeah I have you stay on Oh a
bit and I can see why you choose Kara's
yeah so you mentioned classifying
merchants what kind of features are you
looking at you like you have a string
that you're tokenizing using other
feature data as well like how does that
how does that first is like the time of
the transaction he talkers usually like
and then for instance usually be like
usually it's not like a hard truth like
online shopping can happen at any point
of the day but let's say some some
netflix or like a normal transaction
which is usually occurring during the
business hours that could be one
lightweight feature second could be the
amount of transaction okay the third
would be like if you just bit of
tokenize it sometimes mmm telecom
service so this telecom already gives
you high signals it really doesn't
matter like XYZ telecom or something so
a bit of tokenizer grounds for help
there to feed any like I guess or prior
information in like we just definitely
know that this the string corresponds to
this much and so like so sure try to
learn and because we also have an option
like okay if my classify goes wrong user
can actually say okay whom that is not
category here its category p now that's
actually very valuable source of
information because that's the basic
truth from next time onwards when I
learn something I say like why that
thing was mapping to be very information
that's actually a sad story because we
really don't have like an exhaustive
list of like merchants to its category
master car has an AP it's
really really expensive really expensive
i don't know why but there are some like
and also like you have some for us
companies but in germany you have like a
different set of companies and let's say
people making a purchase in greece you'd
have a different set of company so a
direct mapping or you have to have like
a super exhaustive set of merchants
unfortunately that's not if you have it
i'll be super happy thanks yeah okay
then i would suggest that we think Arn
up again thank you